So after plotting histograms and looking at peoples guesses
about their audience size, I wanted to see how
that matched up with there actual audience size. So
then at that point I turned to scatter plots. So
here's an example of the first scatter plots that
we did looking at this. So on the x
axis is how many people actually saw that post.
And on the Y axis is how many people our
survey respondents guessed saw the post. If they guessed
perfectly accurately, their guess would fall along this dotted diagonal
line. That's the perfect accuracy line. But one of the
things that stands out with, in the scatter plot, is
that you see these horizontal stripes. That's again because
people are guessing these regular numbers. You see a really
clear stripe at about 50 and another really clear stripe
at a hundred, and a little bit of a stripe
at 200. And you really see that these all of this,
the points on the scatter plot are just this big cluster at
the bottom. So people are guessing very small numbers. 20, 50, something
like that, when in reality their audience size is 100 or 200.